[Applause]
[Music]
Nadja can you get me another coke no I'm
good things it's just downstairs
now the Tennessee's home you come to my
house to watch the tennis and y'all even
gonna get me another coat yeah it's the
tiebreaker no that's you know I wish we
had like a really long straw so we don't
have to go downstairs the kitchen that
we just stood Yeah right
how long have a straw could we actually
make that you could use mmm Dan's days
would be a bit of a stretch I reckon
yeah yeah don't think we could throw
ants is that like three or four minutes
yeah we could do it you need a lot of
strolls though I got a pack here oh okay
now our first test just to see that
Nigel can use a straw properly we've got
about a 1 meter length of straw here you
think you didn't suck through that yeah
let's go so we just take these drinking
straws to get along and hopefully yeah
that's all right
well yeah coming through here from the
joins in the straw zone we've got to
come up with some better way to test
this out I happen to have six meters of
plastic tubing --here non-toxic that's
what they said the hardware store all
right we're preparing the preliminary
test Nigel was lowering some tubing off
the balcony he actually thinks he's got
a shot at sucking through six meters
worth of tubing I think he's got no
chance and it's gonna be nowhere close
but this will hopefully allow us to
establish how much Nigel actually sucks
he's getting ready up there he knows
there's a lot riding on it when you
ready whoa look at that look at that
oh he shoots up he's got two meters he's
got three meters look at that guy go
he's getting four meters four meters
five five meters six
yeah I'm gonna try to be the same thing
but the tube I'm using has a thicker
diameter mine is about 5 mil whereas
Nigel's was 3 males so we're gonna see
if this makes any difference
[Music]
now I guess the obvious question is can
Nigel do it not don't think that's the
obvious answer but I'm pretty sure he's
gonna fail but maybe what we're talking
about is how strong works in the first
place how does it work yeah because this
is really just a big bendy straw if we
look at a smaller version of a straw
yeah we should all be familiar with how
this works so should we I don't know I
think most people just think you were
sucking the liquid in and swallowing it
but you kinda have to think about air
pressure yeah because what is actually
happening is that air pressure is what's
causing the coke in this case to go up
the straw well there's a difference in
pressure between the atmospheric
pressure and the pressure that you
create by opening up your lungs and
pulling your diaphragm down do you
reduce the pressure in your mouth and
it's that difference in pressure between
the atmospheric pressure and the
pressure inside you which gets that
liquid flowing into you I feel like I
don't and like someone has failed at the
five millimeter diameter and then you're
the next guy to take it on are you ready
for this I am ready he's practicing his
whole life
yeah you can see it's a strong start go
outside with Kwan we've got it all he's
he's going big right there you can see
there's a lot of determination
getting close
Oh disgusting I definitely felt like my
tongue while I was trying to suck it up
was being pulled out into into the straw
I brought the same there but and it was
tough on definitely tougher well done
sir
thank you means well for his next
challenge we're going to try to get him
to suck through ten point three meters
which is the theoretical maximum size of
straw how are you feeling well
that theoretical maximum kind of relies
on being able to get a perfect vacuum in
although I am perfect in a lot of ways I
don't know that I can create a perfect
vacuum I've often thought that there's
actually a perfect vacuum inside Nigel's
head today we're gonna really find out
won't we yeah okay we've got the setup
here we're down up to Tamra I'm a beach
and we have ten and a half meters worth
of tubing which goes all the way up to
Nigel at the very top there so we're
gonna see if I can relive some of my
former glory and get the red liquid up
this heights three two one there you
have Nigel is starting to suck on that
straw there it goes
looking strong create that vacuum
approaching the edge of the cliff
they're gonna I don't go come on Nigel
doesn't seem to be going anywhere we
seem a bit stuck on that point right
there you can see the determination the
focus trying to see how high that is
he's done well but it just doesn't look
like it's gonna happen
[Music]
all right so Nigel did pretty well there
we saw that he could get the liquid up
that tube about seven meters not the
theoretical maximum of ten meters still
more than you that's a good point that's
a good point
if Nigel could have created a perfect
vacuum then the water would have gone up
to ten point three meters by our
calculations this is kind of similar to
how they used to measure atmospheric
pressure in the old days by millimeters
of mercury
so I'm aspheric pressure would push
mercury up a tube with a vacuum at the
other end 760 millimeters 760
millimeters so about 0.76 of a meter so
you can see why they would have used
mercury and not water because if you
were doing this with water you'd need a
cliff yeah you need a 10 meter long
barometer so yeah much better to do it
with millimeters of mercury and of
course nowadays we measure it in
kiloPascals anyway well done Nigel you
really suck so how do we work out the
maximum length of straw that you could
suck through vertically well think about
this you place the straw into the liquid
and you start sucking from the top that
decreases the pressure at the top and
the difference in pressure between your
mouth and atmospheric pressure creates a
force that pushes the liquid upwards now
that liquid which is in the straw has a
weight which is equal to the volume of
the liquid times its density times the
gravitational field strength so if we
set these two forces equal to each other
you see that the pressure difference
must be equal to the density of fluid
times its height times the gravitational
field strength and if we sub in the
numbers we find that the maximum height
of liquid that anyone could
theoretically lift even if they created
a perfect vacuum inside their mouth
would be about ten point three meters